les policiers perquisitionnent les lieux
ils y trouvent des morceaux de corps
d'orange comme ceux que l'on a retrouvé
près du cadavre DA sunta
dans la forêt de katchera en Galice un
hommage improvisé au pied d'un arbre
[Musique]
des fleurs des peluches et ces quelques
mots reposant paix à
[Musique]
Assunta c'est le nom de cette petite
fille de 12 ans assassinée il y a tout
juste un an retrouvée morte ici
pour ce triste anniversaire il y a
quelques jours des anonymes sont venus
se recueillir
de cette petite fille ça nous a
tellement tous touchés parce qu'on est
des parents on a des enfants nous aussi
cela fait déjà un an que c'est arrivé on
espère que justice sera faite
un an est passé et ses amis de classe
viennent toujours lui rendre hommage
[Applaudissements]
avec elle on aimait se promener et
discuter on parlait de tout
c'était vraiment une bonne amie quand
elle voyait que ça n'allait pas elle
venait toujours me réconforter
il y a les amis les passants mais aussi
les médias espagnols car le meurtre de
cette petite fille a choqué tout le pays
étouffé puis abandonné sur le bord d'un
chemin
Assunta ne présente pas de traces de
coups elle n'a pas été violée le crime
ne ressemble pas à celui d'un prédateur
sexuel pourquoi tu es une petite fille
de la sorte qui aurait pu vouloir s'en
débarrasser au début de l'enquête le
meurtre d'Assunta paraît
incompréhensible
l'histoire de cette petite fille
commence dans le milieu le plus
privilégié de Saint Jacques de
Compostelle ses parents sont des
notables de la ville connu et respectés
Alfonso et journaliste Rosario avocate
le couple ne peut pas avoir d'enfants et
décide d'adopter en Chine
la petite Assunta arrive en Espagne
alors qu'elle n'est qu'un bébé
il y a quatre ans il participe avec elle
à un documentaire sur l'adoption
internationale ils offrent alors à la
caméra l'image d'une famille modèle
dès qu'on a atterri elle a commencé à
pleurer et elle ne s'arrêtait que quand
on la prenait dans les bras Rosario ou
moi il n'y avait que nous deux tout le
monde voulait la prendre dans les bras
mais non elle ne se laissait approcher
par personne d'autre la frontière
c'était deux mètres elle pleurait dès
qu'elle quittait nos bras
la petite Assunta grandit brillante elle
parle trois langues dont le chinois elle
aime la danse et le piano elle est
scolarisée dans cette école la plus côté
de la ville où elle a sauté une classe
ces enseignants choqués refusent de
parler d'humeurtre sa professeur
principal accepte tout juste d'évoquer
le souvenir d'une très bonne élève
c'est très compliqué qu'est-ce que je
peux vous dire et dans la ligne c'était
une enfant qui n'avait aucun problème de
cours elle avait de bonnes relations
avec tout le monde
elle avait des amis
mais je ne peux rien vous dire de plus
et après est-ce que c'est terminé
l'émotion est trop grande ici le meurtre
d'Assunta est devenu tabou
pourtant c'est à l'école que la fillette
montre les premiers signes d'un vrai
malaise au sein de sa famille elle
rentre à ses professeurs d'étranges
poèmes sur sa maman
ma mère est avare et pas très jolie
elle est danseuse mais pas Gracieuse
elle chante mal et cuisine trop salée
elle court très mal et boit beaucoup
ou encore cette mince est jolie femme a
voulu arrêter le vice de la cocaïne et
moi je l'ai aidé pour cela
Assunta tient aussi un blog sur Internet
dans lequel elle exprime des idées
morbides sur cette page où elle écrit en
anglais elle raconte l'histoire d'un
double meurtre dans un parc celui d'un
père et d'une mère assassiné l'un après
l'autre son corps et son esprit sont
restés dans le parc il espère que celui
de sa femme le rejoindra
et puis il y a surtout trois mois avant
sa mort ce texto envoyé à sa meilleure
amie
je suis nerveuse aujourd'hui on a essayé
de me tuer
qui a essayé de te tuer demain je
t'appelle et je te raconte
de quoi sunta a-t-elle peur pourquoi
parle-t-elle autant de morts
d'assassinat dans l'entourage de la
petite fille personne ne prend ses
messages au sérieux on les attribue aux
difficultés apparues dans sa famille
car depuis quelques années le couple
idéal commence à se fissurer il y a deux
ans Rosario et Alfonso
divorcenta à sa mère mais des jeunes
tous les jours chez son père
le 21 septembre au soir Assunta
disparaît
[Musique]
ses parents vont signaler son absence à
la police à 22h30
quelques heures plus tard à 1h du matin
le corps est retrouvé par un passant
dans un chemin forestier
la journaliste Sandra couina est la
première à être arrivée sur les lieux
voilà c'est ici que le corps d'assume ta
a été retrouvé
elle avait la tête
et les pieds par là
posée sur la poitrine comme si la
personne qui l'avait laissé l'art
ressentait de la tendresse pour elle
Assunta est morte étouffée mais elle ne
présente aucune autre trace de violence
sur le corps ce lundi se retrouvait sur
place des cordelettes oranges qui
auraient pu servir à la ligoter
en pleine nuit la police va prévenir sa
mère Rosario à son domicile
après avoir découvert
ert elle est au lit elle dormait
tranquillement une personne qui a perdu
sa fille le soir même qui pense qu'elle
a disparu qu'elle est peut-être morte ne
devrait pas être en train de dormir
tranquillement comme si rien ne s'était
passé
et plus les heures passent plus Rosario
commence à donner des versions
contradictoires sur la disparition de sa
fille et la police commence à la trouver
suspecte
aux policiers la mer raconte toujours la
même histoire elle est allée au centre
commercial elle a laissé Assunta seul
chez elle quand elle est rentrée la
maison était vide
mais les enquêteurs vont se rendre
compte que Rosario ment depuis le début
très vite grâce aux caméras de
surveillance ils vont reconstituer son
après-midi
à 18h15 contrairement à ce qu'elle a dit
elle n'est pas au centre commercial mais
au volant de sa voiture elle s'arrête
devant chez elle puis repart les caméras
captent un passager de petites tailles à
ses côtés pour la police il s'agirait
d'Assunta à la sortie de la ville la
caméra de la station-service la filme
encore une fois la voiture prend la
direction de la maison de campagne de la
famille à une quinzaine de kilomètres de
la ville tout près de la forêt où le
corps d'Assunta a été retrouvé
voilà la maison de campagne du couple
les analyses montreront que le système
d'alarme a été désactivé ce jour-là à
18h33 Rosario y a laissé ses empreintes
digitales elle serait restée sur place
jusqu'à la nuit tombée
pourquoi Rosario a tellement dit sur son
emploi du temps et surtout qu'a-t-elle
fait pendant plus de deux heures dans sa
maison de campagne
les policiers perquisitionnent les lieux
ils y trouvent des morceaux de corps
d'orange comme ceux que l'on a retrouvé
près du cadavre DA sunta
Rosario est arrêté et placé en garde à
vue
devant chez elle la foule a appris la
nouvelle et l'attend pour crier sa haine
pour quelle raison Rosario aurait-elle
voulu se débarrasser de sa fille
les enquêteurs ne sont pas au bout de
leur surprise
l'autopsie va révéler que la mère n'a
pas agisse seule Assunta est morte après
avoir ingéré de très fortes doses d'un
médicament pour adulte un antidépresseur
elle a pris ses médicaments pendant
trois mois avant d'être assassiné
c'est ce que confirme Natalia palmoud
journaliste d'investigation
ce qui est sûr c'est que le jour de sa
mort elle a ingéré de doses massives
d'antidépresseurs
mais à ce moment là cela semble clair
c'était pour pouvoir l'assassiner pour
l'endormir et l'étouffer
mais pourquoi une fillette de 12 ans
prend-elle ce médicament depuis trois
mois
qu'est-ce qui a bien pu se passer dans
cette famille pour en arriver là
qui a donné ses médicaments à Asunta la
police fait le tour des pharmacies et
découvre que cette Alphonse au Lepère
qui a acheté plusieurs fois de cet
antidépresseur avec de fausses
ordonnances le jour de sa mort Assunta
les a ingérés vers 15h alors que ces
deux parents déjeunaient avec elle pour
la police plus de doute la mer et le
père sont complices Alfonso est arrêté
il n'a pas d'alibi le jour d'humeur
pourquoi Rosario et Alfonso aurait-il
assassiné cet enfant qu'ils ont adopté
en Chine plusieurs hypothèses retiennent
l'attention Ricardo Perez Lama et
l'avocat d'une association de protection
de l'enfance qui s'est portée partie
civile pour lui le mobile de ce crime
est psychologique est lié à l'histoire
chaotique du couple et là on a relation
qui est leur relation est fondée sur des
hauts et des bas
ils se mettent ensemble puis divorce
et postérieusement et là Rosario voulait
se remettre à nouveau avec Alfonso
il fonctionne de la même manière avec
leur fille
et l'ont accepté comme leur fille
plus au bout d'un certain moment ils
n'en voulait plus
je sais que c'est difficile à comprendre
mais enfin elle est morte
mais le procureur de Saint-Jacques de
Compostelle retient une autre hypothèse
le père pensait-il que l'arrivée da
sunta avait causé la destruction de leur
couple dans son acte d'accusation le
magistrat notre calfonso voulait se
remettre avec Rosario assassiner leur
fille ensemble les oreillers à jamais la
disparition de sunta de forme violente
et organisée en commun place Rosario
dans les mains d'Alfonso définitivement
procès Louise boutiret est l'avocat de
Rosario pour lui ses scénarios ne
reposent sur rien sa cliente est
innocente
comment elle le dit souvent il n'y a
absolument aucun élément contre elle il
y a deux victimes dans cette affaire la
première c'est bien sûr la petite fille
et la seconde la mer pas de témoin pas
d'aveu quelques indices matériels
fragiles l'avocat avance la thèse d'un
complot montait de toute pièce contre
Rosario et par exemple ces fameuses
cordes oranges qu'on a trouvé dans la
maison de campagne et près du cadavre
dasunta dans la forêt
moi je dis Rosario est une femme
intelligente
depuis des années elle n'est pas assez
stupide pour laisser traîner des preuves
comme ça
il y a quelqu'un dans son entourage qui
a tout manigancé et préparait un
scénario pour que la police tombe sur
elle
incarcéré dans la même prison dans deux
bâtiments séparés Alfonso et Rosario
clament tous les deux leur innocence il
risque la réclusion à perpétuité de sa
cellule Rosario reste la plus combative
l'avocate essaye d'attendrerir l'opinion
publique le jour anniversaire de la mort
de sa fille elle a fait publier 7 en car
dans la presse à sunta je t'aimerai
toujours signer ta maman